so why if you are you know a liberal
Democrat
and you know these companies are
murderous that is part of their business
plan that they are they're it's not even
morally elasticity
it's a complete Detachment from any kind
of moral imperative at all
why would you think
that they're gonna hurt people with all
their other pharmaceutical products
the one product where they can never get
caught and they can never be liable even
if they do get caught
or suddenly you're going to find Jesus
and be you know honorable it it defies
any kind of you know of
um logical uh analysis
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast I have the distinct pleasure and
honor of sitting today with Robert F
Kennedy Jr who is the founder and
chairman of Children's Health defense
and the founder of waterkeeper Alliance
welcome Robert thank you Brad
because maybe Brett's last podcast let's
hope that's not the case but actually I
mean you you joke but I think we should
talk a little bit about the the
predicament here
um
this is Uncharted Territory and I want
to tell you a little bit I don't know
how much
um you are aware but I know a great many
people that we know in common and I keep
having a conversation with people
that I respect
who like and respect you but are afraid
to say so publicly because of the
incredible pushback that you have gotten
since I guess 2005 is that fair
yes and uh I must say I wrestled with
this myself you and I met some months
ago
and I was uh very heartened and
reassured by the person that I met you
are clearly
um a patriot you are clearly a person
who is intensely committed to doing the
right thing and you have had to make
incredible sacrifices
um sacrifices are something the Kennedy
family has made uh at a level that is
almost impossible to imagine and you
have paid incredible prices personally
for the stances that you have taken and
among other things I just want to point
out I know that many people who do tune
into this podcast will presumably have
disagreements with you perhaps over the
interpretation of evidence but
at the very least
you are clearly a person who believes in
what he is doing and is willing to pay a
price to get it done and I don't think
the world can ask any more of anyone
even if you were incorrect about the
interpretation of the evidence which I
don't think you are it would still be
um
it is still an absolute requirement for
the rest of us to recognize that a
person doing what they believe
to be the right thing is an honorable
person and should be treated as such
well I would I would say is that
the the character traits that you
describe Are all objectively uh
admirable traits but I would not
consider them admirable if they weren't
accompanied by an additional trait which
was a willingness to look at Contra
evidence
and willing is to recognize that you're
wrong and to admit that
if the evidence goes against one of your
hypotheses or suppositions and that's
something I feel that
um is part of my makeup I don't know I
if somebody you know knives this from
the beginning
xiaomi data that says I'm wrong and I
will publicly in fact if you can show me
data
that shows that people for example who
get the covet vaccine
are more likely to live and have
healthier lives than people who aren't I
will fold my tent and go back to
protecting you know Rivers full time
um but we don't have that data and my
demand has not been to get rid of
vaccines it's either bad but just as a
let's have the kind of uh randomized
Placebo or other evidence real evidence
you know randomized we'll see about
tests are not the only
go into scientific evidence any evidence
that actually shows that the the all you
know the health outcomes are better
among the people who take the
intervention and people who don't
yes I I completely accept and agree with
your uh your improvement to my model
somebody who does what they think is the
right thing but uh resists evidence that
they are incorrect is a is a hazard if
they get it wrong they can do harm and
so I agree with you and I also um aspire
to that same that same standard
but in any case I I do want to say that
I
um not only have you opened my eyes to a
number of things
um but I also just simply appreciate
your commitment to doing what is
necessary uh in spite of the cost
because I know they have been tremendous
so um uh I regard you as a patriot I
know that I'm a patriot and one Patriot
to another uh I I appreciate what you
have done for us thank you
um now there's a lot of
uh
preliminary work that I think we need to
do to get to the conversation that I
hope to have the conversation ultimately
will center around your new book the
real Anthony fauci now I must confess I
have tried to read this book I tried to
triage it in advance of this podcast but
there wasn't enough time and uh triaging
it turned out to be almost impossible
because virtually every paragraph
contains something jaw-dropping and so
um I did find it a bit of a slow read
but uh absolutely captivating but in any
case when we get to that part of the
conversation I think you're going to
have to lead me through it because I
didn't get very far in advance of our
conversation but I do want to clear
something up
for uh for our viewers and listeners
um your voice has a wobble to it
um I know there's a story here and I
know that you don't uh like talking
about it and I think I know that that's
not because it's personally troubling to
you but your concern uh is that it will
be misinterpreted
um if you talk about uh where this may
have come from but I think actually it
probably makes sense just to clear the
air so what is the wobble in your voice
well I I really don't know where it
comes from I know that I got it I had a
very very strong voice until 1996.
I was 42 years old my voice
and
um the it's it it is called asthmatic
disc on here
and I had no inkling many many years
actors have said to me did you have some
trauma at the time that because
apparently you know onset of this
disease which affects I don't know how
many people but there's a significant
number maybe
50 or 60 000 people are affected in this
country
uh but the onset of the disease
um is often accompanied by trauma so
what two years ago I was reading
um I was actually I Was preparing a
racketeering against a bunch of vaccine
companies for vaccine companies
that make all 72 of the childhood the
mandatory childhood vaccines that are
given to children in this country
and for the first time I had to go
through the manufacturer's insert of
every one of those vaccines when I got
to the flu vaccine
I realized for the first time there's uh
420 side effects
list it is vaccines inside of X on those
inserts
and I had never read them all the way
through
when I was doing the flu vaccine section
I saw that many of the flu vaccines
listed as Monica dystonia as one of the
side effects known side of X and
they have to get an FDA approval to put
that side effect on there
on their manufacturers and certain FDA
under federal law has to agree that
there's a probability based on the
evidence at that injury is caused by the
vaccine
oh this was only two years ago and I've
been working on vaccine issues since
2005 and people would have asked me do
you have any vaccine injuries in your
family or among people who are close to
you and I would say no
for the first time I recognized that
there's a possibility at my injury the
the reason it's a possibility is because
at that point in my life
I was teaching at page University Law
School in White Plains New York
and right next to my clinic where I
taught it was the school Infirmary
and the infirmary every year would post
design and saying come get your flu shot
and every year I went in and I flew the
shot
oh in 1996 I got a flu shot and I have
no idea whether that flu shot caused
this condition but it is on now at least
a hypothesis and uh it's possible that
you don't remember the dates well enough
but if you do the onset of the condition
was following the flu shot that year and
not too far or something long exactly
all right well that's that's fascinating
so it's only in the last couple of years
that you've even potentially connected
the dots between uh your voice condition
and uh and vaccines now I must say I'm
also beginning to wonder about something
that has affected My Life
um and that is as my viewers know I have
a severe wheat allergy right the tiniest
amount of wheat in something that sets
off a Cascade of symptoms and basically
I until I discovered that I was allergic
to wheat I had I think uh basically
continual inflammation
um having gotten wheat out of my diet
the inflammation is cleared up lots of
things I didn't know were symptoms of
anything went away and improved the
quality of my life dramatically and when
I accidentally get wheat because
somebody hasn't been clear on where
there is wheat the symptoms come rushing
back so
um I know I have this Condition it's
mysterious to me and has been for a long
time because my ancestors have been
eating Wheaton for thousands of years
um and I had uh thought I had a model in
my mind of
um the they're being exposure of things
in the gut to elements of the immune
system that are not actually supposed to
contact the contents of the gut which
regard the food contents as foreign and
they fight right basically develop an
allergy because a part of your immune
system is seeing molecules that it
shouldn't and what I did not understand
at the time I must say I don't know and
I will ask you shortly
um how you regard yourself you know if
there is such a thing as an anti-vaxxer
and if there are such uh people if you
are one but I am certainly I would say
almost the opposite I am a huge fan of
vaccination I have lectured on the
beauty and elegance of this mechanism
and to this day I believe it is the most
powerful tool in our medical toolkit
however what I did not realize was that
the thing I had been lecturing on that
is to say the
um borrowing of the immune system the
sending information into the system of
BNT cells so that they are alerted in
advance of pathogens that one's
ancestors have never seen that mechanism
is only part of what goes into a modern
vaccine and there are other elements for
example these adjuvants
um which effectively uh they irritate
the immune system so that it reacts more
strongly so that the vaccine is more
effective and you know in principle sure
that's a great idea on
the other hand
aggravating one's immune system may have
arbitrary consequences and nobody ever
told me that you know you're getting
this vaccine you should be especially
careful about contacting certain kinds
of molecules about other things you
might do because if you in the period
and frankly I don't know how long the
immune system is in this excited state
after one is vaccinated
but these these adjuvants have the
potential to intervene in arbitrary ways
and cause you not only to have a strong
reaction to the antigens in a
traditional vaccine but they can also
cause you to react to other things that
are present in in your body
um so I had not put that together that
means I am now wondering if I might be
suffering from a uh a vaccine adverse
event and I will likely never know
um well there are you know it's
interesting because of
first of all there's a lot of potential
culprits and as you know I did I was on
the trial team in the Monsanto case in
Monsanto
um was you know has this uh herbicide
which is glyphosate based
and one of the things we know about
glyphosate is that it interferes with
the shikame pathway which is the pathway
that your microbiome uses to regulate
immune responses and
um the in 2006
Monsanto told Farmers to start
spraying life is head unto wheat in the
at Harvest Time as a desiccant to dry
out the crop to avoid mold and at
actually the largest sales of glyphosate
I think about 70 of the sales have
occurred since then and for the first
time they were spraying it on food
because most of the use of glyphosate
is early in the growing season when
you're trying to fight weeds before the
you know allow the corn to grow up above
them
it also it never been sprayed on a week
before because they have Roundup Ready
corn but they don't have around any
wheat or at least it didn't and
huge amount of Life say were were
sprayed on the corn on the weed and
people in our country and around the
world begin having Celiac diseases and
gluten allergies
um at a rate beginning in 2006 we had
never seen before so there you know
or all swimming around in a toxic soup
right now and you can't really pinpoint
one culprit and I I don't know and a an
outcome like you have
I will say this on the vaccine adjuvant
here's what happened the original
vaccines were live virus vaccines
polio vaccine and and smallpox vaccine
what happened is that
they realize that if you give somebody a
live virus vaccine it can
um it can mutate in your body and your
gut
and you can and create a more virulent
form of the vaccine what you're doing is
you're giving people a
a a a a
um
a
disarmed version of Iris so unless the
Ireland form of the virus which will
give you immunity against all forms
including a much more viral and deadly
forms
but the virus when they use eye virus
vaccine get more offend your body and it
can turn into it can turn pathogenic and
fairly and transmissible and
um for example today 70 of the polio in
the world is vaccine strained so it's
coming from vaccinated individuals
this is what who acknowledges
oh very early on in vaccinology
the regulatory agency's Express
preference or dead virus vaccines so you
disable the virus you give a fraction of
it or you kill it and then give it to
people
the problem is the dead virus vaccines
do not provoke
a durable and robust immune response
that you need to get a license
and if actionologists discovered very
early on was that if you add something
horrendously toxic to the vaccine that
the body it kind of shocks the body and
the body then remembers the antigen and
Associates it Associates with a toxic
element
and so there was a search around the
world by vaccinologists for the most
toxic elements in the universe
and they began adding Mercury which is a
thousand times more neurotoxic than lead
and it is the most toxic element in the
universe that we know about that is not
radioactive right I was going to say
plutonium is so
um
uh but and Mercury was discontent he got
a really bad name
was discontinued in most of the American
vaccines in 2003 with the exception of
the flu vaccine and it was replaced by
aluminum and you saw but there was
aluminum throughout
what you went what we've seen in this
country the vaccine schedule exploded in
1989. we went from the three vaccines
that I got it as a kid
72 vaccine doses it's 72 dose of 16
vaccines that my children's generation
got and it happened very quickly
beginning around 1989 and you started
seeing these explosions of
developmental disorders ADD ADHD speech
language like a text red syndrome an
article FC
as the autism went from one in ten
thousand in my generation in your
generation to one in 22 Boys in our
children's generation
um food allergies like
peanut allergies also eczema anaphylaxis
asthma allergic to these
and then a third category of diseases
also became epidemic the autoimmune
disease like rheumatoid arthritis and
juvenile diabetes
and most people think at the uh that the
Allergic Disease we began saying was a
result of the illuminum adjuvant because
the aluminum is put in the vaccine to
prompt essentially an allergic response
uh heightened antibody response
and it turns out
that it's not just you know there are
things like peanut oil excipients in the
vaccine
itself so you make an allergic response
to that but it also
um things that are in the ambient
environment at that time appear to also
get targeted by that response as you
just pointed out so if you have a
Timothy weed outbreak the wheat that you
get that vaccine
you may have now a lifetime allergy to
Timothy weight and there's two
scientists uh one called cowlings and
another called Anthony Mawson
looked on studies that show that
children who have vaccinated have 30
times the rate of allergic rhinitis as
children who are not vaccinated now I
had 11 brothers and sisters
I have something like 71st cousins on
both sides
and I didn't know anybody with a food
allergy growing up
and yet my children almost all of my six
children have allergies
and so we know that something happened
and when Congress told EPA
what year did for example the autism
epidemic began
EPA scientists came back and said it was
1989. and so some and that's the year
that the vaccine schedule exploded it
doesn't mean it's all coming from
vaccines because there's other things
that happen on that timeline like pfoas
which are flame retardants which became
ubiquitous glyphosate around that time
became ubiquitous self on radiation uh
ultrasound neonicotoid passes it's a
number of others so you can't pinpoint
one toxin
but as they it make vaccines make it
very good culprit because of those
adjuvants the advents are designed to
give you allergies and allergies
suddenly beginning in 1989 it's hard to
find somebody prior to 1989 who has a
peanut allergy right people it's pretty
easy like in every classroom or fine
people
we went
um during
we went from having six percent of
Americans having chronic diseases in
by 1986 we had 11.8 and by 2054 and the
big change happened in 1989. well so
this actually Treads into the uh the
area that that Heather and my book is
focused on what we call hyper novelty
and I think people need to start
thinking about the puzzles
about what's wrong with them
in a different way right it may be you
know you can have an argument about a
particular uh cause and whether it leads
to autism for example right and lots of
people can shut down that argument and
they can say well this doesn't cause
autism we've established that but the
question is well then what does there's
something in the environment if there is
an increase in the rate of this disorder
it is implausible that it would be a
change in the underlying genes so it's
something that we are allowing to
interface with children
jeans
as you know genes don't cause epidemics
right they may provide the vulnerability
and there are some groups that are more
vulnerable but you need an environmental
toxin that's just pure science right
oh there's a very very famous scientist
um I think you know Mount Zion I called
Phil Landry and I've actually you know
used him as an expert in in some of our
cases he's one of the you know the
leading kind of toxicologists in the
world
and he has looked at this problem that
you're talking about and said why did
all these things happen essentially
beginning you know in the early 1990s
why was this this huge explosion of
chronic disease yeah and he he came down
with 11 Suspects
things that you have to find something
that became ubiquitous in that period so
it has to be something
effectively equally Cubans and keep his
game Miami and Inuit in Homer Alaska
right and there's only a certain number
of interventions that occurred during
that period that you can blame but it's
an easy it's an easy scientific problem
to solve if you were government
officials interested if you were
inclined to solve it originally the
people who are responsible for all of
those toxic exposures are also the most
powerful lot in groups in the United
States economy and in Washington right
so we I don't even know what the
description of this problem is but in
some sense you have a
um
the fox
inherits the role of guarding the
chicken coop I I don't know I'd say that
fox is guarding the fox
Cooper yeah it's it's something along
these lines but nonetheless we you know
in instance after instance we play this
game where we rule out causes in order
to exonerate some group of people that
has altered something and the problem is
we don't then go to the next step and
say look it is something that's causing
the uptick therefore we you know if you
really wanted to address the issue you
would figure out what was doing it so
even if you can't help people who've
already been affected you could prevent
it from affecting anybody new and the
problem is
that there's also an entire industry of
what we call biostitutes which are these
you know phony
um uh mercenary scientists for a higher
who can drama particularly
epidemiological studies which are very
very susceptible to corruption in order
to exclude a certain cause in my racket
which is plain as
um litigation
and pharmaceuticalytic Asian and
litigation against polluters we have a
saying that that statistics don't lie
but statisticians do and also there's
another saying that uh that you know
statistics are like prisoners of war or
they'll say anything you want if you
torture them enough and these guys are
experts
of taking industry money and then
torturing data to make it I exclude a
certain uh and to exonerate a certain
culprit and so when government officials
say well
um we have excluded that we know it's
not that you also need to say show me
the actual study because I don't
actually believe anything that you say
and then you need to read that study and
you need to read it critically because
as you know the scientific journals have
also been captured by the industry and
when you know it's just something is
peer-reviewed it does not mean it's true
you have to read it critically right no
peer review well you know Heather and I
sometimes uh say that peer review is
different than review by one's peers
right we think peer review is just you
know it's something you can interpret in
a straightforward common parlance way
but no no no no it's a very corrupt
process but actually this leads and I
don't mean
I think one of the things that kind of
led me to where I am today is I have
kind of a unique job which is you know
is litigating as powerful polluters
that has put me in this niche of
um of of having to study peer-reviewed
Publications and to read them critically
and even the ones that I'm not smart
enough to read critically I need to find
somebody who can and say I suspect they
cheated here tell me how they did it you
know and and oh I'm oh you know I don't
automatically believe peer review and I
know that you that there are certain
tricks that they all use and there's
gimmicks and there's you know the
stratification of data and there's
exclusionary criteria
and all these uh these tricks that they
use to get any outcome that they want
all right and I think it's going to be
hard for people who haven't encountered
it in a professional context to even
comprehend what you're getting at but
the fact is and you know this is another
place Heather and I say that science is
an extremely powerful process but it's
also extremely fragile right in order to
get the scientific method to work it has
to be insulated from things like Market
forces Market Force is completely
overwhelm the scientific method and what
you're saying can be translated as
um any hypothesis can be falsified for a
price right if you want to run a study
that falsifies the connection between A
and B it can be done and so the problem
is you have to figure out how to exclude
studies that are built to do that and
leave only studies that actually
um meet the bare minimum requirements of
an actual scientific test which is not
easy you can't always spot it you know
the best
anybody who doubts that that's happening
should look at the testimony of people
like Richard Horton
who is a scoundrel oh you know but I
highly respect anyone who's run the
lands that I don't know which is the
eyes
scientific and medical journal for
decades and he says in it there's he's
as we have become propaganda vessels for
the pharmaceutical industry that there's
basically nothing in our Journal
you can believe it or Marcia angle
who was until recently the editor of the
New England Journal of Medicine who has
written the books and exactly the same
thing
are the editors of the is
highest weight journals all of them have
acknowledged that what is published in
their journals is not necessarily truth
and that more often it isn't truth it's
uh
it's a profit making mercenary
propaganda by you know people who have a
lot of mistake in saying I have a
scientifically ratified product which
results in something the public is
completely incapable of navigating which
is a world in which basically you have
two kinds of cherry picking pitted
against each other You've Got The
Honorable cherry picking where you are
trying to get rid of the stuff that
isn't right because it was built to fail
right and you've got the exact opposite
in which a false picture is being
painted for some purpose you don't
necessarily even know and this is not an
environment that is conducive to
figuring out what's true right because
really then it becomes a question of you
know who do you trust and that's not a
scientific question right that's the
opposite of science right
is a logical fallacy right oh
um you can't do it that way yeah and
that's right I mean they
you know the essential sort of intention
of
um liberal democracy and other science
and medicine and even law
has been the
um the discernment or the search for
existential truths and you know we're
all walking around at this point in a
Wilderness of mirrors you know that has
been deliberately constructed to lie to
us and to deceive us about where the
truth actually lies right which all
right I don't even know where to start
here but let me just say
um
your book
it has thrown a certain number of people
uh that I quite respect these are people
who are on the front lines fighting the
good fight who do know this material and
yet in diving into your book they are
thrown because of what they didn't know
right there's something about the uh you
know I don't know how to describe it
exactly but to the extent that I've been
into your book it feels to me like
um
a beautifully written indictment right
so it is in its own way encyclopedic in
going through the history of these uh
conclusions of the history of the people
involved in making them and drawing
connections and here's what I'm getting
at
I've long been focused on political
corruption and capture I've long been
aware that capture is an inadequate term
right regulatory capture is too narrow
to describe what we see almost anywhere
right regulatory capture is really about
regulatory agencies that begin to
function on behalf of the uh the sectors
that they they become sock puppets for
the industry that they're supposed to be
regulating right but that does not cover
what we begin to see right for the FDA
to be
um corrupted by Pharma is not surprising
it's tragic it's dangerous but it's not
surprising
for Google to be in on it is
a new twist and so I don't know what the
right term for what we see is as a
placeholder I've been saying something
like extended capture right it's capture
of all of the things necessary in order
to create what you're describing as a
Hall of Mirrors
um I would say it's a it's an entirely
potemkin Public Health narrative
and so before I got to your book
um
I've obviously been uh talking to
Heather and Pierre Corey and and Robert
Malone and and all of these folks about
what we're seeing and we are all it's
all it's like we're backstage right we
can see the thing happening in front of
us it's not that hard to see if you know
where to stand but the public can't
understand what they're seeing
um and here's the the little puzzle that
I'm left with
if I look at the public health
recommendations for for covid
I think that the public health
recommendations are the exact inverse of
what one would do if one wanted to
control this disease and minimize the
harm from it it's not
that they're bad and arbitrary and wrong
it's the inverse right you can't get to
the inverse through incompetence that
would be impossible right you would get
arbitrary from incompetence what we have
is uh you know we have drugs that work
early
what's the recommendation that we don't
treat you until very late in the
progression of disease right when we
know that the stuff that we have that
works doesn't work anymore right where
do we send you we send you home where
you're going to get people who you live
with sick right all of these things
don't make any sense so we use exactly
the things that don't work REM death
severe doesn't work it's a dangerous
drug that doesn't work and we use that
we don't use the safe drugs that do work
right so again it's the inverse of what
you would expect if we were trying to
control the pandemic now somebody
watching may hear me say that and say
Brett's lost his mind right he's got it
exactly upside down and the I think you
know an honest broker who's walking into
this conversation for the first time has
to wonder who has it exactly wrong
somebody does right it could be me but
it could also be you know Tony fauci for
example now your book comes at this
puzzle
and what it does that um
I think is so valuable is it begins to
lead people through how you might end up
at a response that was upside down right
upside down is a very troubling thing
and it suggests I mean what do you do
about a a public health apparatus that's
doing the exact inverse of what you're
supposed to do how do you even turn it
around right it has to go 180 degrees in
the other direction in order to be
effective
um and I don't even know that there's
precedent for that
um so I guess
it's a Hall of Mirrors it's a potemkin
Public Health response it's the inverse
of what we should do it creates
um
a vast Chasm between people who are
making sense and people who are not
which makes it much harder for people
you know to dip their toe in the water
and begin to you know to listen to the
other side
um so
what do you see where are we right
you're you're shocking people with your
book is there a way out of this
well
um that's a huge question I really don't
deal with in the book what is the way
out of this and what you know I think
the way that you put this I I kind of
wish I had some of that language
um in the conclusion of the book because
it's a way of saying something is really
wrong here without actually trying to
read people's minds and attributing
attribute motives to them
and I try to avoid that throughout the
book I don't say here's why you know
Tony thought she was scheming to do this
I just show he's recurring patterns of
behavior that began early on in his
career and then again and again and
again
worked for him the alliances were the
pharmaceutical industry the capacity
uh to control science to suppress
science to punish scientists who were
you know publishing
a contrary science
and to really control the the
extraordinary hegemony that he has
over a global scientific research not
only what gets funded but also what gets
oppressed
between him and his two partners Jeremy
Ferrara one runs the welcome trust and
Bill Gates
on they control 61 percent of the
biomedical research in the world and
they the those three men
have used the same pattern of of control
of the manipulation of fear of the um
generation of
um of fake pandemics and I'm not saying
this one is a fake pandemic because it
isn't
but throughout their careers they've
repeatedly faked pandemics
and I show all that well
um and I don't you know I try not to
look into their heads and you know and
speculate I just really try to tell uh
give the facts about
what happened and out of these recurring
patterns you can see that there is
something truly wrong now how do we
correct that
the brief answer to that is we need to
fix democracy which is not a you know I
mean the problem is I you know I feel
like I saw all this happening beginning
because of the nature of my work as an
environmental Advocate and just being
part of the family that I'm part of I
saw this trajectory of of how
corporations take control and you know
execute essentially accudate against
against democracy
and over a long period of time and you
know part of it is
um you know the the uh
I'm getting rid of campaign Finance
reform and unleashing is huge synonyms
of money that are coming into all of
these mechanisms of corruption including
all the well-documented
um mechanisms of agency capture that
always are happening in a democracy
I'm a you know we've now we've really
now I I believe kind of obliterated
democracy in our country
and even my party the Democratic Party
has at Red realizes that and they
realize that democracy I mean the the
whole theme of the censorship Drive
which the Democratic party 80 of
Democrats now believe that censorship is
an okay thing
and that's extraordinary because we all
grew up reading and you know Robert
Heinlein and you know Aldous Huxley and
um and uh Soldier needs and we know that
censorship always leads to tyranny
or how you know why is it that 80 78 80
of Democrats now endorse it and what
does that mean what it means
fundamentally is it they've lost how
they've lost faith in democracy
they ain't now believe that the people
the demos
cannot be trusted with information and
that the information has to be
manipulated changed diffused before it's
given to them
and that the government ought to be in
charge of that process and ought to
collaborate with these Titans like Mark
Zuckerberg and Google
to make sure the population is
controlled which is the opposite of of
democracy and so you know when you ask
how do you fix it we need to really
um
let me go back and say one thing
uh give a hopeful message because I
don't want to depress everybody
but we lost democracy and another era in
American history which was during the
Gilded Age in the 1890s you know 1900s
where
you had a few of these very very wealthy
it's very analogous or what's happening
now the Carnegie is in the Rockefellers
and the melons and the Morgans
and the Fricks who were who controlled
not only the entire economy
but also at that point there was no
direct election of senators and a um and
so they were hand-picking senators and
democracy really disappeared in America
and you had what what you had the press
that rose up at these muckraking
journalists you had a populist movement
in the countryside the Progressive
Movement in the cities
and you had a very Dynamic leader Teddy
Roosevelt who came in and they you know
they
passed the Sherman Antitrust Act they
forced
um they had graduated income tax for the
first time they abolished they created
the 40-hour work week they gave women
the vote abolished child labor
um they gave they allowed unions
actually function and they as far as
they restored democracy in many ways I
think it can happen the problem is today
you know this is not just tyranny it's
totalitarianism and what is the
difference totalitarianism seeks to
control the way people think every
aspect of your life and they have for
the first time in history
the capacity that kind of Total Control
you know the Chinese are not using
facial recognition systems that can tell
whether you look guilty
and you know we're seeing these track
and Trace surveillance now that I think
is really
um it's a daunting obstacle to the
restoration of democracy but yeah well
um I see the same picture I must say I'm
a bit concerned about a couple things I
I agree it is also it is still possible
to rescue democracy and in fact that we
don't really have any choice and
um during the last election I tried to
make this uh this point I launched Unity
2020 which was a plan for doing just
that and actually we we did quite well
we reached a lot of folks it obviously
wasn't going to turn the election but
um but nonetheless I do believe it's
possible I believe it's it's very late
but not too late
um on the other hand I think some new
things are stacked against us and it's
very hard to get people to spot them
one of them
I'm watching all sorts of people who
understood the problem of
authoritarianism when it came to woke
ideology lots of people who saw through
it and did not uh cut into the the
authoritarian impulse
they are on a different side with
respect to the public health response
they are quite convinced I think that
the lies they are being told are noble
lies and therefore it's time for us all
to get on board to get past covet and
they do not understand there is no plan
here to get past covet that's not what's
being deployed and they've got it wrong
those aren't Noble lies at all so even
journalists
who
um would have been the people I would
expect to out the uh whatever this
pattern is and to say this makes no
sense nothing about this is what you
would do if you were trying to control
covet those people have by and large
been quiet and I think they've been
quiet because as soon as you step into a
scientific milieu many people who would
otherwise have the courage of their
convictions start uh cowing to Authority
because they don't
they don't in internally feel entitled
to challenge uh things that are patently
wrong right they feel they they're
outranked by someone so I I worry I
worry about that and I also worry that
the nature of the censorship is now
[Music]
um
maybe it's not even just the censorship
the nature of the Tyranny is now much
more Surgical
and so because there's a lot more
capacity to you know you don't used to
be that if the uh the intelligence
agencies wanted to spy on somebody it
was an effort they had to spend on it
and which meant that they couldn't just
spy on everybody and
um that limited the amount of spying
that got done presumably this is a
practical matter
now because we're all transmitting
virtually everything through channels
that can be uh just simply captured it's
become impossibly cheap and they don't
even need to know who they're spying on
they just collect it all and then at the
point you become trouble they look into
what you've said they can map your
entire social landscape and figure out
who you trust who you don't trust what
your blind spots are whatever it is they
want to know they can do it
um which means and then they can punish
you instantly by cutting off your money
yourself well and all of the
you know without any kind of due process
or trial or even a regulatory
involvement they can tell you don't
travel
it can deny you access to your job to
your education to basic rights are now
rewards for compliance and obedience
rather than you know the rights that you
can't take from me no matter what right
now uh they're now all along they're
just they're they're cookies he'll give
you they give you for you know uh for
demonstrating obedience right which
means that
um they have a great deal more leverage
over those people who would stand up and
say no people like you
um right you are being ruthlessly
punished for disagreeing and I think it
will be any honest broker who listens to
this conversation or any other
conversation that you've had will hear a
careful thoughtful person who is trying
to make sense out of a complex
um a complex crisis right but the point
is
for somebody who doesn't know what you
think I haven't looked at your Wikipedia
page but I would guess that there's a
lot of colorful stuff on it as there is
on my Wikipedia page stuff designed to
cause anybody who might be tempted to
listen to you to back away because they
don't want to get near the um
the social contagion that comes from the
various stigmas and epithets that are
directed your way
um in any case my overarching point is
the modern tools have made it possible
to prevent change much more surgically
which leaves most people unaware that
this force that prevents change is is
doing this right because it has far more
information and it has far it has as you
point out all sorts of mechanisms to
reward and punish
um those that it wants to and I I worry
we're going to have to think our way
around that puzzle in order to to make
change and we have to make change
because we're obviously I mean as you
point out it would appear that even the
Democratic party has lost faith in the
idea of um of democracy and the consent
of the governed and frankly rule of law
and everything else
um
I guess I do have to ask you I'm also a
lifelong Democrat
do you do you have any hope left for the
party
um well I I don't think that we can win
without you know getting a substantial
part of the people a number of the
people who are
now subsumed in the Orthodoxy of
Democrats who are symptoms in the
Orthodoxy who are well-intentioned
um I I just don't see it and we those
people if we're going to win this battle
we need to wake them up and one of the
things that I really try to do in my
communications
is to avoid the polarization isn't on to
point my finger at this part here at
that party
or at race or you know the vaccinated
person in fact all the way all the
mechanisms that you use to divide us
which I believe are strategic in order
to protect you know the uh the best
interest and the elites
and we need to stop
um fighting with each other and I think
we need to turn you know the Democratic
party around and it's not
I mean it's really stunning at what's
happened the the attack that the
outright coup d'etat I guess democracy
and against constitutional governance
that's happened in the past 20 months
because we've seen you know James
Madison but um
said that Jefferson and and Adams and
the other framers put the First
Amendment
freedom of speech and expression into
the Earth's Amendment because all of the
other amendments depend on it
and we saw them immediately ago after
the first amendment in fact
in October of 2019
when the virus was already almost
certainly circulating in Wuhan
um they had this you know this pandemic
um
uh a tabletop simulation in New York
called uh called uh event 201
and were they
were they they did a you know they did a
simulation of a coronavirus a global
coronavirus at a time when it was Bill
Gates it was April Haynes the former
deputy director of the CIA
uh pharmaceutical people John Johnson
and Johnson people from the
the uh from the social media and from
the mainstream media and they're all
sitting around a table
simulating what's going to happen if a
coronavirus pandemic hits is quite
extraordinary but the response
that they're talking about has nothing
to do with a Medical Response it's all
about using the pandemic
or if every militarized response and a
monetized response they use the pandemic
as an excuse to clam down totalitarian
controls and they spend the entire
foresight and anybody can go and look at
this you know it's still on YouTube
and and you know a two-hour discussion
talking about how to so how to censor
social media when people start saying
that the coronavirus was laboratory
generated and you have
the head of Chinese CDC George gay oh
there you have to see how the person who
is now Obama's highest ahead of the
National Security Agency and that's what
they're all talking about
oh and as soon as the pandemic came
that's the first thing they did is I
started censoring everybody well once
they did that and what Madison said
is the reason they put it in the first
amendment is because once you give a
license to a government
the silent speech the government has a
license to commit any address including
abolishing all the other amendments so
then they got rid of the you know the
other part of the first amendment is
religion
they shut down the churches for a year
without due process without any science
being shown without any public hearings
no notice and comment rulemaking
and they kept the liquor stores open as
essential businesses
oh you know which I don't have an
objection a lot of people liquor stores
are essential but
liquor stores are not in the
Constitution and churches are so there
should have been some
public National discussion of that and
some science demonstrating that this was
something that was going to work and
they shut down jury trials
is that the sixth amendment Seventh
Amendment says
no American shall be denied the right of
a trial
before his peers in case their
controversies exceeding 25 in value
well they passed the prep Act and the
cares Act is that if a vaccine company
or any other corporation that says it's
involved in counter measures
Andrews or kills you no matter how
negligent they are no matter how
Reckless
no matter how Grievous your injury you
cannot sue them
a property rights they closed a million
businesses with no due process no just
compensation they got rid of all of the
prohibitions against
one of the searches and seizures you
know with all this track and tracing
surveillance that they implemented
and they got rid of due process of law
government is no longer by public
hearing and you know notice and comment
rule making and you show me the science
and all cross-examine you and you
cross-examine me
it's just one doctor
who's saying put on masks
uh you know lockdown without any
scientific justification no argument and
that is so frightening and so
disconcerting to I think anybody who
understands how democracy got rid of
every Amendment except the Second
Amendment which is the guns the rest of
them are all gone right
um so all right so they got rid of it
all
one doctor
what are the chances that that doctor
would also be one of two people who
appears potentially to have been
responsible for the pandemic in the
first place yeah I mean that's the big
question
and
um you know I have a chapter in the book
about I have a couple of chapters that
are um you know about uh
how Dr fauci ended up doing these kind
of function experiments
and what happened is that
the I mean if you go back just
historically and I'll make this very
brave
when I was a kid I think this is a long
story but when I was seven years old uh
President Eisenhower made what is today
probably the greatest speech in America
most important speech American history
where he warned Americans against the
obliteration of democracy if we allow
the military industrial complex uh to
continue to exp and to emerge and and
dominate you know democracy
my uncle took over his presence in three
days later
I was at that inauguration
he spends his three years fighting the
military industrial complex dies my
father runs five years later I'm running
against the military and Dodger complex
the Vietnam War
he dies during that campaign and then in
and you see the expansion with Nixon
coming in and you know the military
getting more and contractors taking more
and more control of American democracy
in 89
the communism collapses and we're all
told we're going to get a piece of it
and and you know that the money that
went into that
billion dollar stealth bomber that
cannot fly in a ray in the rain okay
that that billion dollars is now going
to go to schools hospitals and Roads and
you know and health care and improving
quality of life and we're all saying
this is going to be great we're gonna
on the weapons into plowshares
but there were people in our
you know in who were like listening to
that and saying that's coming out at
least evidence coming out of my pocket
of 93
or years later we have the first
terrorist attack and there's a
screeching all to all that money that
was headed towards civilians is now
it goes into terrorism Islamic terrorism
and it gives us justification to be have
bases and you know 670 bases and
countries across the world and all of
this you know this Global hegemony
but
Atomic terrorism has a problem
because it's hard to justify these huge
allocations of our GNP
to a harm or potential or risk that
kills fewer people every year Americans
every year than lightning strikes
and when the World Trade Center attack
occurred in 2001.
three weeks later there was an Anthrax
attack
and that and our country you know first
Bush and then Obama
said that declared officially official
documents that bio security is now the
spear tip of American foreign policy and
germs are much more appealing than
Islamic terrorism because germs can get
into everybody's home and they can kill
you
and people have a natural repugnance of
germs and it's easy to exploit that fear
to get them to give up their
constitutional rights and to turn this
into a National Security State
ruled by the people that our eyes now
are warned us against
oh without you as part of that you know
that Anthrax attack was used as a
justification to to invade Iraq it
turned out we found out later that the
anthrax came from one of three U.S
military Labs somebody in the U.S
military that was Associated and it had
nothing to do with Saddam
a military began and people who were
involved in BIO Warfare began funneling
huge amounts of money into bio Warfare
it's illegal in 72 we signed the treaty
we closed all of our BioWare Warfare
Labs Nixon signed the treaty saying
we're never going to do it again we're
not never going to we're not going to
create them we're not going to study
them we're not going to
I use them and we're not going to to
store them
Iowa weapons so the military wanted to
do bio weapons research
but it was scared to because of the
legal violations and so they started
taking this money
and funneling agents specifically Tony
ouchy so
beginning in 2001 immediately after
those attacks he began receiving 1.6
billion dollars a year
or to do essentially bio weapons
research there's a loophole in the
bioweapons treaty
that says you the you can do bioweapons
research as long as it's what they call
dual use oh as long as you can say
you're developing vaccines
you can develop bioweapons
and
Tony fauci had a personal stake in this
it gave him a payoff which is they gave
him
and the Pentagon government that money
he also got a 68 pay raise
that is attached to his bio weapons
research Tony fauci today is highest
paid official in the U.S government he
gets 434 thousand dollars a year the
president that's only four hundred
thousand it was the next biggest oh and
why does he get that he gets almost 70
percent of it comes from his military
work
oh he is taught he has a 6.1 billion
dollar budget which is money just he
just gives away two scientists to do you
know to do basically drug development
and then he has an additional 1.6
billion so it's uh it's about 7.7
billion altogether
it comes from the military and that he
had to justify by doing these gain of
function studies and you know at first
it was completely unregulated
he really and I talked in the book about
how he manipulated the regulation and
got controls the committee that we're
supposed to be over to seeing him by
putting his grantees on those committees
and he began and then in a bunch of the
bugs escaped in 2014 and 300 scientists
signed a letter to Obama saying you got
to stop essentially Tony fauci from
making any more of these bugs
and that year he began
transferring his studies to the Wuhan
lab the Chinese were welcoming them and
the Chinese were and wuong lab is run by
the Chinese military
you can outwork in that lab without some
association with the Chinese military in
the Chinese military
are very Frank what they're doing is a
weapons development
and so you had all this this group of
characters very you know interesting and
uh
um people like Ralph Eric from the
University of North Carolina and uh
Peter dazak who had their own
self-interest at and made excuses to
themselves that they were
you know doing the I mean listen
Tony fauci is saying it out of the
corner of his mouth he's saying we're
doing this in order to develop vaccines
is countermeasured
the people who know most about this area
like Mark lipsich of Harvard and
um and Richard ebright a bunch of others
hey there's not a single development
that has come out of gain of function
research that has helped in any pandemic
including this one
is worthless research
but Tony foutch himself was funding
Ralph Barrick
to create
um these legation processes where you
not only are developing these pandemic
superbugs you're also developing
methodologies for hiding the fact that
they were bioengineered oh the nocium
edits no CM edits oh and the interesting
thing about that is how do you justify
them why in the world why is that
a benefit to Public Health right under
one baby and fauci was funding that
right and you you would you would in
fact want the exact opposite because you
would want the ability to at least know
when something you had done exactly
caused a harm
um yeah that's that's incredible and I
mean again I I just think people okay
you've got two narratives one is we're
doing the best we can it's the
unvaccinated we're causing this pandemic
to go on and on and we've got the tool
at our disposal and people just need to
use it okay that's obvious nonsense but
nonetheless that's the story
um and then you've got the alternative
narrative which is actually the vaccines
interesting as they are as a
technological Discovery have multiple
design failures within them they are
weak as can be which anybody you don't
need any biological knowledge whatsoever
to recognize that if they've faded to
the point you need a booster in six
months this isn't much of a vaccine by
any standard right so but also there's
no pretense that they prevent
transmission right so oh and it's this
incredible cognitive dissonance this
incredible intellectual discontent
uh people your friends are telling you
you can't come to my party because
you're unvaccinated and you can't even
say to them but vaccines but Tony fauci
says vaccines don't prevent transmission
right and you can tell somebody that
fact
and the reaction will be to get furious
at you rather than say oh
um and how am I protected
we know that vaccinated people are
equally likely from all the data that we
have
to pass the illness they may you know
there's a lot of data that says if
you're vaccinated you're more likely
yeah well I can't say that's true
because
um we do not have because nobody's you
know funding the science that show that
but the science that we have
and also common sense
and this is what Luke montenero who
discovered you know the one upriser just
got ring
the HIV virus in 1993
and what he said from the beginning if
you if you vaccinate people with what
they call a leaky vaccine which is a
vaccine that does not prevent
transmission during the height of a
pandemic
you are turning every vaccinated person
into a mutant Factory you're actually
it's a each person is a a Serial passage
gain of function experiment
the same reason that sub-therapeutic
antibiotics right exactly generate
um generate uh antibiotics resistant
superbugs a vaccine that is
sub-therapeutic is gonna is by every
from anybody who understands natural
selection or biological evolution would
immediately say of course that is going
to create mutant superbugs right now and
they've played this game they've played
it with me and I don't much like it
because they accuse me of not
understanding what I'm talking about
when in fact what they're doing is just
playing a linguistic game we say Escape
mutants right that puts the emphasis on
mutation and so they make this argument
that the number of cases is is
proportional to the amount of mutation
which is of course true but it's the
selection for the mutants that are
resistant to these vaccines that is
driving this so the these are Escape
variants which is the result of
selection which is very definitely
happening in those who have been
vaccinated
what's more and this is
again very hard to convey to people who
haven't been paying attention but
covet is not the worst disease it might
be from the point of view of the
symptoms but it's very bad on its own
right it does damage to many different
types of tissue it does tags all organs
right essentially all organs which I
take to be indicative actually of the
likely origin from the lab because most
bugs have to pay attention to you know
keeping you on your feet so you spread
them but in a laboratory things are very
different if you're spreading it in a
tissue or in an animal that doesn't have
to forage right
if you are a passage and
you want your host to be eating drinking
having sex going to parties right um and
and because you the advantage goes to
the ones that are not sickening at
reorgan in their host right so this is a
bad disease and Heather and I have said
that from the beginning this is a
dangerous disease those who downplay it
were making a mistake the irony is that
this is actually changed this was a very
dangerous disease until some very good
dedicated doctors figured out how to
treat it right it is now a very
manageable disease except for the fact
that all of the tools that would prevent
it and are useful in treating it are
being removed from the table as quickly
as possible and so the idea that you
know it isn't one you know yes
Ivermectin indeed there's a really good
drug that works really well in this case
we know that from Doctor's clinical
experience likewise hydroxychloroquine
but even if you take those off the table
we still have a whole host of substances
that work and we actually in fact have
substances that prevent people from
coming down with it and yet our Public
Health response does not include a
discussion of things like vitamin D and
zinc and magnesium right this is
unconscionable right we are actually
talking about a disease that at Great
cost we have learned how to deal with it
does not require us to lock down the
world at this moment because we have
enough knowledge but we're not deploying
it and so what they've effectively left
us is a vaccine that is effectively an
interesting prototype right not nearly
well enough understood not nearly safe
enough to be deployed into the public
not Justified on the basis that it
doesn't as you point out prevent
transmission
right we have this prototype vaccine
being deployed as if it's a solution to
the pandemic and the actual Solutions
are being uh kept out of play and that
is keeping this disease much more
dangerous than it actually is or would
need to be at this point this is
preposterous it's the up upside down
inverse Public Health response and the
problem I mean really let's let's talk
about the actual problem the actual
problem is if what I just said is true
then the world is upside down that
leaves the person watching this podcast
with nothing to grab onto okay so there
are some Renegades who say we're doing
the exact inverse of what we should be
doing even if you would acknowledge that
it doesn't tell you how you change
anything so you know at least I think
people are simply doubling down on the
idea that the public health authorities
must be doing the right thing because if
they're not it's hopeless yeah and it's
hard you you know you discredit yourself
and marginalize yourself if you
even by inventorying all the like bad
things they do because the the
um
the
conclusion that you kind of growl
yourself into is feeling like a you know
a lot of evidence that they're
deliberately doing things that they know
are wrong to harm public health and you
know that's
for most people that's
um it's impossible to believe I
when I was
um studying along later when I was
teaching litigation
one of the things that we always that I
taught you know my students when they're
talking to a jury
you never tell the jury that all doctors
are wrong about this you you really
targeted to that doctor because the jury
does not want to believe all doctors I
only want to believe something's wrong
with that doctor who you're selling
and I think it it just is it's
unacceptable to people that at these you
know that these medical officials who
are
in charge of Our Lives May have bad
motivations and I don't even go into
that in my book because I try to stay
away from the motive but I do lay out
this very damning case you and I talked
earlier today about what happened in
China and we don't really know but why
how the Chinese
were able to deal with this uh this
pandemic so quickly the eliminated by
April so you know April 2020.
so they had a two-month pandemic and it
was gone
and
um but we know that the Chinese did
exactly the opposite of what we did if
they they did really tracking and
tracing which is
they figured out who was infected and
they immediately isolated them and then
they gave them an early treatment and
they had by April they had published an
early treatment protocol
which included chloroquine which is a
form of hydroxycline because of
hydroxychloroquine and it and it
included all kinds of herbs that have
kerosene and them and zinc and
vitamin D all the things that we know
work and many many others and you know
and antibiotics and anti-inflammatories
and all the things that you
have to do to uh to deal with this
multifaceted disease
and we did the opposite this goes to
your
um your supposition that
we did the inverse of what you're
supposed to do
the Chinese took people were sick and
immediately treated them even if they
didn't have any symptoms
[Music]
Tony fauci his procedure was if you came
in and you got a positive test
they sent you home to infect your family
and to get yourself so sick you couldn't
breathe and then come into the hospital
and get REM deserve which is deadly
so deadly that it was pulled in 2019
on the study on Ebola because it was
killing so many people more than the
four other drugs and this was Tony
fauci's study and the the uh the safety
review board said you cannot give this
to a bowl of victims because it's too
dangerous and now this is the only drug
that we have you know other than
monoclonal
um antibodies is the only approved drug
for Covenant and it is one of the most
dangerous right and also the
lethality of that drug mimics Clovis so
it's kidney collapses lung collapse you
know as pulmonary injuries so people
don't know whether it's the drug killing
him or the covet
and to get ventilators right oh that
Tony fauci's prescription is waited home
in Terror
tell your two you're so sick that you're
not getting enough oxygen in your blood
come to the hospital and we're going to
give you remedies of air which is deadly
and ventilators which are deadly the
Chinese did the opposite they said as
soon as we know you're sick we're
getting you out of the population so you
can't infect other people we're going to
give you treatment so you never have to
go to a hospital
and you know that what we did is the
opposite of quarantine right it is the
exact opposite of what everybody who has
done
epidemic Management in the history of
medicine who knows that you quarantine
the second you do not quarantine the
healthy yeah well not only we we
quarantined the healthy and then we send
it home to them we sent the sick home
and then we nuke the economy so that
everybody's sitting at home
to get infected right it is it is
literally the exact opposite of of what
you would do reasonable and even if
somehow that was an accident at the
point that it didn't work and we racked
up extremely high levels of mortality
for this disease we should have realized
hey something we're doing is wrong
we knew from the beginning that this was
a this was an indoor ailment yep the
people who were locked in you know in
senior centers Elder Care Homes
it raised through those areas and killed
everybody
yep and
um and so you know why and we don't see
it spreading Outdoors right so so what
do we do why do we lock everybody inside
closed the beaches right we closed the
the the the parks we we give thousand
dollar tickets to Surfers right who are
in the sun getting vitamin D yes Heather
and I were yelling about this was like
well you know I mean at some level they
caused us to view the entire world as
dangerous when 99 of the world was safe
right by masking the healthy and I must
say this is one of the places I did get
wrong I initially thought masks were
likely to work I masked before almost
anyone in my community in fact I
developed a reputation at the hardware
store as we were preparing for lockdown
and building our studio I would go in
there Mast and they started referring to
me as the Bandit because I had a bandana
on these things don't actually work
nearly as well as people think they do
in fact the cloth masks probably don't
work at all but nonetheless all right I
got that one wrong but what are we doing
we're putting masks on everyone all of
the healthy people which creates this
ever present reminder right
and I think actually you do talk about
this in your book that there is the
psychological aspect of to the extent
that we have two we have two diseases
one is covid and the other is
authoritarianism yeah yeah right and so
that authoritarian thing depends on
people feeling frightened and feeling uh
you know uncertain about each other
right the whole idea pandemic of the
unvaccinated that was nonsense yeah and
the master amplifiers for fear right
they cause you the point is if you were
if we were to view this disease as it
actually is the answer is you step
outside your door into the outside world
you have become very nearly safe right
to the extent that you wish to interact
with other human beings and you do it in
that outside environment you are very
nearly safe and that ought to be a
tremendous relief it gives us a loophole
in this disease that we can exploit to
retain our humanity and to interact with
each other in normal Ways by doing so
and you know maybe you would interact at
home before and you find a way to
interact Outdoors now and it gives you
normalcy and the thing is just as we are
doing the wrong thing medically and
epidemiologically to control this
disease we are also doing the wrong
things socially right we are amping up
people's fear and irrationally so and
there's no excuse for it but it's all
part of hey if it would be a good idea
we're going to do the opposite right and
you know if another thing
in pandemic management
you want to reduce stress on people you
don't want to say you no longer have a
job but you don't want to say that you
know we're not going to let you see your
parents we're not we're gonna we're
going to remove you we're not going to
allow you to make facial expressions
We're not gonna allow you to kiss your
children or children to get it to hug
each other at school
you don't want to you know
all of the responses you never saw
Anthony fauci act like America's doctor
I'm kind of getting up boy Roosevelt I
wouldn't say
the only thing we have to fear is fear
itself
that fear is the enemy and don't be
scared let's act we're actually let's
take care of each other
let's have a Medical Response let's make
it let's make sure everybody has access
to vitamin D
let's tell people to get outside to
exercise to lose weight
to avoid chemical residues in your food
to avoid sugar drinks to uh to do all
the things that you would want a doctor
and then and then
if you ask what should Tony fast you've
done
the first thing he should have done it
is to create there's 11 million between
11 and 15 million doctors in the world
many of them working on the front line
with coveted patients how do you create
a communication grid connects all those
people so that
if somebody in India or Tanzania
is having extraordinary success
how do you measure that how do you
calibrate it and how do you communicate
that act to an analytics Center all
these guys Gates and Larry Ellison and
Google people
I want we creating a network grid we did
the opposite to figure out what is the
best existing therapeutic drugs or
treating these diseases where are people
showing us publishing every day in real
time
the best treatment protocols they've
instead they did the opposite they kept
us
from accessing those treatment protocols
they had
you know Burke's Redfield
ouchy on the stage every day doing these
you know these press conferences
none of those people ever treated a
covid case right so we were getting our
information
um people who had no experience treating
these cases all the front line doctors
who are treating thousands of patients
and getting different results
I weren't we distilling that information
and you know Gathering it collecting it
distilling and aggregating it and then
turning it into useful treatment
protocols that you could you know update
every single day
to this day
Tony fauci has never published a
treatment protocol
early treatment of covid
the Chinese did it by the end of March
and they had obliterated the Disease by
April it
you're a hundred percent right that we
should have had a doctor's networking to
figure out what worked right that could
have very quickly generated very high
quality information and again it's not
even that we didn't do it
we literally did the opposite right we
are now demonizing and demonizing and
marginalizing and villified we are
vilifying the very doctors who figured
out how to do it in fact
I don't know that I'm at Liberty to say
who but
um I was told
of a doctor who has had excellent
success with early treatment of covid
who has literally been forbidden by his
hospital to prescribe the drugs that he
knows work and he is now being forced to
attend effectively the slow deaths of
patients he knows he could say oh right
this is preposterous right and you know
and I know the doctor that you're
talking about in Virginia I think and if
it's the right one but
he um you know he's one of the most
published and respected doctors in his
field in America and was and it has a
track record of saving lives of having a
infection fatality rates that are a
quarter or a third or a fifth of what
all his colleagues have because he's
been doing these early treatments this
is the doctor you want
exactly that's the doctor you want and
he you know in in Massachusetts now
they're they're
um
very illegalizing
prescriptions or ivermectin for any
purpose yep to keep people from getting
life-saving medications and you know you
look at this and say how are they
orchestrating this
yeah and I I I okay you and I don't know
what drives the individuals who are
making these bad decisions but you don't
really need to right at the point that
you discover hey this looks like the
inverse of a good protocol
um there's a conspicua I've noticed the
following pattern there are lots of
doctors who uh will argue that something
like Ivermectin is ineffective and there
are lots of other doctors who will say
it's effective I have yet to encounter
the Doctor Who who has prescribed it who
says it's ineffective right you've got a
lot of people who are effectively
armchair doctoring who will swear to
this one thing but all of the people who
have tried it seem to find it's
effective now I I don't know if I say
that here on this podcaster is there
going to be a race is there a price
point to generate a doctor who will
swear he's tried it and it doesn't work
I don't know but I have yet to see that
pattern at all so at the point you
discover that the doctors that do have
good track records are using various
things
um that are being there's obviously a
massive campaign to shape public opinion
around these medications
at the point you discover all that's
happening and then you spot that the
person who is in charge of our response
also happens to be one of two people who
are plausibly
um causal of the pandemic who seems to
have circumvented actually federal law
and gain of function research and
offshored it to a lab that appears to
have leaked this pathogen into the world
how is it that the person who appears to
be import in the causal chain of this
pandemic and is now
apparently mismanaging it at the level
of not just incompetence but inverting
the best protocols
you don't need to know what's on his
mind you just need to fire him
he just needs to go right it would be
hard to do worse than we are doing
and
um you know that doesn't require us to
know anything beyond uh where these I
mean
what am I trying to say if your public
health officials aren't even
recommending vitamin D
this far into this pandemic then
there's no excuse we could replace them
with any one of a number of people and
instantly improve our response to this
and our failure to do it suggests that
something isn't interested in
controlling the disease
there's a very
um
uh
uh powerful Orthodox as uh it has
compromised the essential intention of
some of the key institutions in our
democracy the uh the institutions that
are supposed to serve the public
interest in public health
um I have now been subverted in this you
know in a way that really is a kind of
coup d'etat against democracy and
it's you you can see the people who are
involved in fortifying the Orthodoxy
it's clearly the pharmaceutical
companies we're making a lot of money
is the
um it's the internet tightens oh you
know there's been a transfer in wealth
of
the latest figures I've seen of 3.8
trillion dollars
from middle class to the super rich
there's a handful of billionaires who
are mainly the Silicon Valley
billionaires
and medium ogles who are making uh on
the lockdown
are making billions are amplifying their
wealth in these incredible ways and
and nobody's saying well they're also
the ones who are censoring
any criticism or questions of the
lockdown
and then
um you know there are other sort of
Institutions that are involved in the
captive agencies
have long ago been co-opted by
the pharmaceutical paradigm and uh and
then the mainstream media which you know
they the pharmaceutical companies
America uh there's two countries in the
world
that allow direct consumer advertising
by pharmaceutical companies and this is
one of the elements that has really
facilitated the Takeover of these you
know the fortification of this Orthodoxy
of Pharma spends about 9.6 billion
dollars in advertising directly to
Consumers there's well the only other
nation is New Zealand Every Other Nation
says no pharmaceutical companies can't
advertise on TV are you out of your mind
because we know what they're going to do
they're going to create you know demands
for drugs that people don't need
and it's predictable we use three times
the amount of drugs that the average
Western Nation uses we pay the highest
price for pharmaceuticals in the world
and we have the worst
Health outcomes in the developed world
and
I think we're 79th you know they're
different in Isha like
um like infant mortality but we're at
the bottom for everything and when I was
a kid
America had the best health system in
the world now we have the worst in the
western world
and Tony Archie over 50 years has
supervised that supervised the
decimation of American
medical system by Health Care system
I essentially turning it over to the
pharmaceutical industry what he's done
and this is what people need to
understand with his agency
is he has transformed that agency into
an incubator for pharmaceutical products
so it used to be that
the reason that the National Institute
for allergic and infectious disease was
launched was to
establish the ideology
of infectious disease autoimmune
diseases and allergic diseases
trying to figure out how to cure them
and or how to stop them now to prevent
them and so we've had under his watch
we've had this explosion in chronic
disease the chronic diseases he's meant
to prevent have gone from six percent of
them affecting six percent of Americans
with acting at least 54 percent of
Americans as of 2006
and so what is he doing with all this
money here's what he's doing he's
developing drugs to sell to Americans
with the pharmaceutical companies and
this is how the system essentially works
he has Laboratories where
NIH Nia IDs scientists test molecules in
Petri dishes that are filled with viral
cultures oh he'll have Coxsackievirus
and Dengue virus and zika virus and
Ebola and and coronavirus and flu
viruses and thousands
Petri dishes and they'll drop Molly this
is a simplification of you know of what
happens
and they'll drop molecules certain
Innovative molecules
into that patronage and see if it kills
the virus if it kills the virus they now
have an antiviral
but they have to make sure that it won't
kill the person
they give it to rats and see or other
you know lab animals and see if it kills
them and if ideally it will kill the
virus but it won't kill the rat so now
they have a potential drug now they Farm
it out
to a college to a university and this is
how he really has the whole system
rigged that people have to understand
he there's a group a class of scientists
that are called principal investigators
and the people that you see on CNN every
night Peter Oates are Kaplan Paul off it
you know Stanley Pearlman all the people
who represent themselves as experts
they're not independent experts they're
almost all of them are principal
investigators who are who are rely for
their livelihood on grants from NIH
they're usually powerful individuals at
a university like Harvard or Baylor or
Columbia or Stanford and at the medical
school
they'll be the dean of the department
the chair of the department or a dean
and they're the ones who are bringing
all the money into that school because
the big money now in medicine is in
clinical trials
so that drug that Tony she's developed
in his lab he now sends over to one of
those Pia pis to do uh phase one trials
they'll have 50 or 100 humans that they
give it to
and and
NIH will give that the pi the principal
investigator fifteen to twenty thousand
dollars per subject for every patient
they recruit for the trial
the pi gets 20 000. the University
skims off 50 to 75 percent of that so
now you have the university that's on
the hook right that can be controlled
because they're making their money from
fauces you know grants
Eric goes to age two and sometime
between phase two and phase three
when you have maybe 20 000 subjects and
huge amounts of money
they now transfer the patent to a
pharmaceutical company so they'll bring
in Gilead or Johnson Johnson or
Murchison
and that company now
share partners with Nia age and with the
university in completing that study
and
Tony fauci can keep part of the patent
or his agency
he can distribute patents to his
loyalists within the agency who he
favors who are allowed to get on or
allowed to own part of the patent of any
drug they work on if Tony fauci okay is
it
and they can get a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year in royalties for
life so with the modern vaccine he's
given either four or six
of his top deputies these royalty rights
so they're going to make 150 Grand a
year
he's got 50 of that patent for NIH so
it's going to make billions
the university that worked on it
is gets a part of the patent and so they
can make potentially billions hundreds
of millions and the P I guess it gets a
piece of it
oh you have this whole system where now
he controls the university so
um so what happens is and and here's how
powerful he is how much influence that
has
between 2009 and 2016.
there were over 200 drugs approved by
FDA most of the drugs approved during
that area during that era that all came
out of town if you shop
so that is how deeply embedded he is
in the pharmaceutical industry
he doesn't do Public Health
he does development that's his job
if you ask Tony fauci are Americans uh
healthier since you came in he's not
going to tell you that he doesn't know
he is not looking at that metric he's
looking at how many people got
vaccinated how many people got you know
this drug that drug
and
um and you know so the and the metrics
by which people so with the other and
and let's say
here's how he controls the science
let's say there's a young
scientist a young Professor associate
professor at
um at Stanford or Baylor
who says hey
there's a Kaiser permanent there's a
Kaiser HMO database
it has 200 patients in it for a 20-year
20 years of data on 200 patients and
they have all the vaccination records
for every one of them
down to the batch number and they have
all of the health claims for diabetes
for epipens for allergies Etc
I could go in there and do a cluster
analysis and see whether any of these
batches or vaccines are associated with
a greater risk or incident for the
illnesses genius idea easy to do
and so he proposes that
well immediately the dean of his medical
school
is going to get a call from uh Hugh walk
and Claus or Cliff lane or one of a
fauci's deputies who tell them if you
let that clown do this study you know
you're going to lose 300 million dollars
next year and we're going to bankrupt
you so you know nothing gets done
anything that is going to challenge
his worldview any science just doesn't
get done and these three guys Jeremy
Ferrar who was part of the cover of it
gain a function
Bill Gates and fauci control 61 of the
biomedical research in the world so
research does not get done
unless it's going to benefit a
pharmaceutical company it's all been
turned over and then you have an agency
look I
I've known about it agency capture my
whole life
probably 20 of the cases that I brought
when I was running water keeper Alliance
and and running the litigation Clinic it
pays
were against
EPA or State Health agencies like the
easy in New York probably 20 to 30
percent I wasn't suing polluters I was
suing the agency
who was making the illegal sweetheart
deals with the polluters to allow them
to pollute
oh I'm known about agency capture my you
know my whole career I've been for 40
years I've been suing a captive
regulators
but when I started doing the vaccine
work in 2005 I've never seen anything
like this because
FDA gets 50 of its budget between 40 and
50 every year
on the pharmaceutical industry
CDC has a 12 billion dollar budget and
4.9 billion of that so you know about 40
percent
is goes to buying vaccines and then
Distributing them so they're a vaccine
company
the way you get promotions
raises salary evaluations bonuses at CDC
is by showing that you helped with
vaccine uptake
and and I I CDC owns 57 vaccine patents
NIH owns over a thousand patents
and makes money on the sales of drugs
that it's supposed to regulate
so it's like if this is agency capture
on steroids it's like if EPA was making
50 of its budget you know from from cold
company revenues
that's the same thing that we'd be
dealing with this is a this is an agency
that no longer has any interest
in public health it's completely about
expanding the profit and revenues of the
pharmaceutical industry who are its
patrons so
I believe I understand what you just
told me some of it's very familiar to me
some of it's new
um it appears to be a an environment in
which corruption evolves that's the
thing is it's actually adaptation in a
darwinian sense that enlarges the
capture so the thing that you and I are
familiar with from 25 30 years ago about
regulatory capture has evolved into some
2.0 or 3.0 version of that which is much
more elaborate but it does make sense
then of the inverse Public Health
response
because the thing is
to the extent that humans get control of
covid it shuts down this brand new
gigantic market for pharmaceutical
products and so should something in that
evolved environment recognize that the
interest the long-term interest of the
pharmaceutical companies at the level of
their financial well-being involves
uh keeping this disease
um around and frightening and therefore
increasing demand for its product demand
which isn't even really demand uh to the
extent that government is going to
mandate it in order for you to have a
driver's license over whatever it is
that they're going to to hold in reserve
um this is a a perfect environment and
what I don't really understand maybe
maybe you can help me sort this out let
me just add an identity to that sure
the vaccine companies have no liability
so no matter how badly in they injure
you you can't sue them
and if they
impose an injury that is a chronic
disease injury like diabetes or seizure
disorders whatever
they've now created a lifetime
customer or their other products
and this it will sound so cynical to
many of your listeners that they
probably won't want to dismiss what I'm
saying
and so I'm not even saying gonna say
that they do that with their conscience
of it I'm saying that those when those
incentives exist
it is bad for us Society you know the
the what we want to do in an economic
system and a democratic system is
incentivized good behavior and punish
bad behavior and we want to create an
economy that does those things and
economic rules that do those things and
we've created the opposite so
it is actually true that that's all you
have to do I know this sounds wrong but
if that's all you do that you know it
yeah but it it will sound wrong to many
but if that's all you did was create a
system in which externalizing harm onto
others was costly and innovating uh
actual generation of wealth rather than
transfer of wealth uh paid if that's all
you did the system would evolve towards
producing benefits and it would avoid
and that's the answer to the first
question that we began with how do you
reclaim the system you create you
rationalize the economic rules
that they do what we want an economy to
do which is to reward good behavior and
punish bad behavior and because you
cannot legislate morality right you know
but you can you can create incentives
that reward moral behavior and that
punish immoral Behavior that's exactly
right if you set it if you set up those
rules so that uh people who are inclined
to behave morally actually do well than
morality spreads yeah
um you you want to make it
you want to allow people to do well by
doing good right rather than
incentivizing them to make money by
harming other people and externalizing
their their you know the their profits
right and if you're just the other side
of that boundary and you actually allow
people to profit through externalizing
harm what you get is uh capture 3.0
because what happens is those who have
control over something enlarge their
control and anyway you end up with this
shocking uh elaborate Baroque system in
which somehow you know uh YouTube is now
shutting down people who say true things
into a camera on behalf of
pharmaceutical companies
um and you know nobody sees it coming I
am stunned in my own
Social Circles
at the
unwillingness of anybody who has not
seen the full picture
to recognize that
pharmaceutical skullduggery
three years ago would not have been
controversial
um in any group of intelligent people
having a conversation about policy it
was simply expected
that there was regulatory capture and
that uh evidence didn't necessarily
mean what it appeared to mean in other
words all intelligent people would have
taken it uh as an assumption that there
was some degree of corruption in policy
that affects Pharmaceuticals
during the pandemic the only people who
talk about this are people who in my
opinion have their eyes open and have
seen just how bad the policy is there's
no ability to even raise the question
others simply assume corruption is
playing no role here
how can that be
you know it's part of this
uh very very I mean inexplicable
um
uh disconnect
cognitive disconnect
I I mean like a company or companies
and make all of the U.S vaccines
have those which are sign up fee is
there Axel and erk
collectively have paid
excuse me 35 billion dollars
since 2009's over a 10-year period
in criminal penalties in Damages uh for
falsifying Scions for lying to
regulators
or uh for bribing blackmailing
and
Physicians and and Regulatory officials
and those companies and killing hundreds
of thousands of people with drugs they
knew were lethal for example vioxx uh
killed
between Merck with viox which up until
killed between a hundred and twenty
thousand five hundred thousand Americans
with a drug that they knew was going to
cause those heart attacks in fact when
you know when they when we sue them and
got there
uh they're they're flow charts from
their Bean counters to the to their
legal and marketing officials they said
we're going to kill all these people but
we're still going to make money even if
we have to pay them off
a problem and you can you know every
drug kills somebody
oh you know there's nothing wrong with
marketing a drug that does kill a
certain number of people as long as
you're honest with people about what the
risk is right you know we we live in
with grown-ups and people have to make
assessments about what risk there
are
willing to endure I've heard what
benefits in it but in that case
knew what the risk was and it didn't
tell anybody this oh it was marketing a
headache pill
I didn't know caused heart attacks and
most of the people who took that bill
would probably have said you know what I
I I think I'll take an aspirin
and because I but Merck never let them
make that decision because it never gave
them the data
these companies
um
are the same companies that brought us
the opioid you know Johnson Johnson
the opioid epidemic which is killing 56
000 Americans a year more kids than died
in the 20-year Vietnam but ever we're
having a Vietnam every year from the
opioids and they hatched it they knew it
was going to happen and they did it
anyway
how do you how do you say Okay the
reason that those
that they got caught for those crimes
they paid the 35 billion dollars was
because private plaintiff's attorneys
like myself
sue them on behalf of an injured client
and then in the discovery process came
across documents that showed criminal
conduct and walked those documents down
to the U.S attorney's office and said
you know you need to sue them and put
them in jail
and the only place that can happen is
with vaccines
because in vaccines no matter how badly
they injury you can't sue them so would
you explain no Discovery there's no
deposition there's no class actions
there's no multidisurgation they can
never get caught so why if you are you
know a liberal Democrat
and you know these companies are
murderous that is part of their business
plan that they are they're it's not even
morally elasticity
it's a complete Detachment from any kind
of moral imperative at all
why would you think that they're going
to hurt people with all their other
pharmaceutical products
the one product where they can never get
caught and they can never be liable even
if they do get caught
there suddenly you're going to find
Jesus and be you know honorable it it
defies any kind of you know of
um logical uh analysis I agree it
absolutely defies any kind of logical
analysis to to imagine that you don't at
least have average levels of corruption
in this case and they also there's no
breast scrutiny either none and there's
no political scrutiny so the politicians
won't touch them
you can't bring them in front of a judge
or a law Court
and there's no and the Press you know
defends them no matter what they do
if you're that company why and you
already are corrupt and and homicidal
why would you suddenly you know not see
the enormous opportunity
have said that in 2022 they're going to
make 900 million No 9 billion dot not 96
billion dollars 93 or 96 billion dollars
from vaccines
nobody's made products like profits like
that in history right why would you have
qualms about a few people dying you know
particularly since you're going to
injure people who you can then sell
other products to
right well I mean I I don't know what
these conversations sound like inside
these entities I do know that what they
are producing one can detect from the
outside doesn't make the slightest bit
of sense from the point of view of a
well-intended effort to control the
pandemic to limit the harm of this
disease to save lives any of these
things well here's
here's what people need to understand
about the fighter vaccine the fighter
vaccine we know more about because
they actually have gotten approval for
That vaccine
on the FDA they're not going to Market
they got approval for aversion this was
all a scam
all the culminati okay so it's the same
vaccine but it has a different name yep
and they got approval for that one but
they did not want approval for the bio
and Tech vaccine why didn't they not
want to prove them
hey guys
if they as long as they have emergency
use authorization
they cannot be sued
but once they get approval
how you can sue them that's right if
somebody gets injured for an approved
vaccine you can sue them
the only way they can get a shield from
liability
is if they get it recommended for
children because children's vaccines are
immune for liability
and so and but and the trick is that if
you get it approve of recommended for
children by the CDC
it not only has liability for children's
injuries but it has liability for adult
injuries oh and of this is why they're
driving so hard to vaccinate children
because it's the only way that they can
get liability protection and that is
what this whole game is about they know
the the number the the key metrics and
you need to look at with vaccines is
called nntv the number needed to
vaccinate to save one life what is the
nntv for children
I'll tell you what it is it's hundreds
of thousands you they're because
children don't get healthy children
do not die from covet as with the Lancet
studies they couldn't find anybody in
the world any healthy child who died in
the world from covet
so why would we give this to healthy
children well and they're they're high
risk let me let me just outline one
thing that people really should
understand about this vaccine
when they
Pfizer did the study it was supposed to
be a three-year pre-clinical study and
it was the first time in history
That vaccine has had has been subject to
peer review randomized specific control
trials so it was a good thing we've
never 72 vaccines we have for kids none
of them have gone through those trials
pre-clinical I did not know that I'm not
one and we see them to say I sued them
with Aaron Siri from I can
because for years I was saying this and
they you know Tony asking everybody
saying what he's saying is not true so I
we sued them we said show us one study
for any vaccine but
accuracy answer exam from safety testing
and and that is a historical artifact
that has to do with cdc's Legacy is the
Public Health Service so CDC the Public
Health Service was a military agency
was a military agency and that's why
people at CDC have military ranks like
Surgeon General and they were uniforms
because it's still part of the military
a vaccine program was launched as a
national security defense against
biological attacks on our country so
they wanted to make sure that if the
Russians attacked us with Anthrax or
some other biological agent
we could quickly formulate a vaccine and
and administer it's a 200 million
American civilians with no regulatory
impediments
as you know for most medicines before
they get approval
they need to go through randomized
double blind Placebo studies double
blind meaning the researcher nor the
patient knows which is Placebo and which
is real and those studies normally last
five years and why do they last so long
because medicines cause injuries that
have long diagnostic Horizons or long
incubation periods you do not see them
for five years even five years isn't
long enough to know five years isn't
long enough of course but you know
you need to have that five-year period
so they they didn't want to do that for
vaccines because they're they said we're
going to be under result and we need to
get her right away so they said what
we're going to do is we're going to call
vaccines by a different name because we
call them medicines we need to do those
studies
we'll call them biologics and we'll make
biologics exempt from safety testing so
vaccines are not are the only medical
product or device that never has to go
through safety testing so it was finally
a good thing
they did this for the Pfizer accent now
they were going to do a three-year study
I ended in 2022 or 2023.
but they they stopped it after six
months why do they stop it after six
months well I can't tell you what their
internal discussions were but I can tell
you that the vaccine doesn't work after
six months which you know so if you have
no efficacy
after six months you do have some
advocacy during the first six months so
you can justify it but
those numbers every month you go after
that are going to be dragged down until
the clearly the harms
um you know the arms axis is going to
cross the the efficacy access right and
nobody's going to be able to justify it
so they had to stop it after six months
oh so they unblinded it meaning they
told all the people on the placebo group
you got the placebo and now we're gonna
vaccinate you
oh after that there's no way to do his
studies right because he's now
vaccinated so what so then the advisor
took the data
from that first six months and they
brought it to FDA and they got an
approval
here's the key metrics that you want to
look at all cause mortality
as the vaccine after six months or more
people alive in the vaccine group than
in the placebo group you want that to be
that's the case
here's what happened of the 22 000
people in the vaccine group
20 died
of the 22 000 people in the placebo
group 14 died
so the risk
of getting the vaccine it includes a 48
greater risk of death according to their
own clinical trials
how in the world
would FDA approve a product
at their own data
show that it has a 48 you have a 48
greater risk of dying in six months if
you get the vaccine here's why
there were two people in the placebo
group who died of covet
it was one per of the 22 000 during that
sixth month two in the placebo group
died of Cove
it was one person who died in the
vaccine group of covid
therefore Pfizer was able to make the
claim that the vaccine is a hundred
percent effective against covet because
two
is a hundred percent greater than one
so so uh now one one Americans here the
vaccine it's 100 which Tony Foundation
everybody repeat
what they think that means is that if I
take the vaccine I 100 chance of not
dying from coven
that's not what it means so but they're
not telling you that it's a it's a trick
that a gimmick they use is called
relative risk instead of absolute risk
instead of absolutely yeah so and here's
what
the even worse news is
in the VAC in the vaccine in the placebo
group one person died of a heart attack
in the vaccine group five people died of
heart attacks
oh there's a 500 increased risk for
heart attack if you get the vaccine by
their own numbers
and furthermore
there is a there's a a every life that's
saved from from covid
before people die
from the vaccine
that's not a good metric
from art attacks so every life itself
four people die
from from vaccine related heart attacks
and they
and to go back to where we started what
then is the number needed to vaccinate
or to avoid a different covet you need
to vaccinate 22 000 people to save one
life
you better make sure that that vaccine
is so safe that none of those 22 000 are
going to die from the vaccine
but they're on data say that five five
of those people are going to die from
heart attack four excess deaths because
there's one in the placebo group that
died
and you have to none of those people
were kids it was only 1300 kids in the
study so and we know that Pfizer lied
because we know that Maddie Gary who is
at a 13 year old girl and that's a study
she got seizures immediately after the
vaccine she ends up apparently permanent
paralysis in a wheelchair for Life
eating out of a feeding tube
and Pfizer wrote that down told FDA that
was a stomach ache
oh we know there was cheating going on
so we do know there was cheating going
on if I remember the story correctly
basically they declared it a stomachache
which allowed them to unblind at which
point they stopped recording so that it
doesn't get recorded at the full level
of harm right is that is that correct
yes yeah so we do know that there were
Shenanigans of all kinds we also know in
your description of all of these things
are all of the things that you actually
want to measure this is not a hard
problem right
legally
before FDA approves a vaccine you know
there's that committee called verb backy
and it is not actually FDA it's a panel
in FDA that is made up mainly of Anthony
fauci's pis
and then there's another panel that were
recommended in other words mandated in
CDC which is called advisory committee
for immunization practices and they also
are Johnny found she's bis he keeps
saying there's an independent panel
that's like they're not independent it
worked for him and for Bill Gates
oh
those people are required by law to know
the number needed to vaccinate that is a
key metric that they must consider and
he had
a network considered it approve the
vaccine without considering something
they would legally obligated to consider
okay so they approved it even though
number needed to treat doesn't justify
especially in light of a vaccine that is
as unusual
as novel as these vaccines are they
didn't know this number and then in the
aftermath they are not monitoring all
cause mortality and so the point is we
are specifically whatever the
explanation is whatever the conversation
sound like we are specifically avoiding
the measures that would allow us to
detect if we were making a mistake let's
say it's an honest mistake if it's an
honest mistake yes and then you take the
measures and oh my goodness we're
actually you know the all-cause
mortality does not support the use of
these vaccines and that's before we even
get to whatever their long-term arms
might be right that would be a stopping
condition but by not monitoring this
right by vaccinating a control group so
that you can no longer tell whether or
not the people in the control group are
actually healthier we're blinding
ourselves yeah and not only that but we
they deliberately have a injury
surveillance system that is intended to
fail it was built to fails oh that's the
vaccine adverse event reporting system
which is the system that it's a
voluntary system
if you get a vaccine injury your doctor
is supposedly required to report it
I'm bye it's up to him to decide whether
it was a vaccine injury but boy most
doctors don't want to report it many of
them don't even know about the system
but most of them don't recognize vaccine
injuries
if you die within three months of
vaccine you should be reported no matter
what you died of
that should be part of the database and
it should be and and under the law if
you're part of a clinical trial
every death during a clinical trial must
be attributed to the intervention unless
proven otherwise so we should have the
same rule that if somebody dies two or
three months after the vaccine it's
assumed to be vaccine related until
proven otherwise
in fact what happens is almost no
vaccine injuries get reported if you're
the doctor yeah
and you tell the patient
or you tell the family this you your dad
needs to get this vaccine
and or he's going to die and they say
well what you know could it hurt him and
he says no it's totally safe it's proven
safe
he gives it to him the father and eyes
17 days later
and are they and most deaths 99 of that
there's no autopsy for older people
there's never an autopsy almost never
autops it costs five thousand dollars so
people aren't going to do it so
the doctor's incentives to say no no I
did not kill your father
the vaccine did not kill them right
right this is human nature yeah people
die so they don't report it Affairs
nothing gets reported and
actually we've known this for decades
and important people have who are part
of the you know medical
mainstream like David Kessler's former
Surgeon General
I said this this system is completely
broken
as a result of that in 2010
HHS
High retain or contracted a sub-agency
the agency for healthcare research HR
research quality hrcq
study the fair system to see how
effective it was and
ahrq and to develop a machine counting
system
that would not have the defects of a
voluntary system that and so how do you
do that
it's easy to do
you go to the hmos the hmos have all the
vaccine records of every patient they
have all the medical claims and you do
like I said before a cluster analysis
and you get
95 of vaccine injuries are gonna appear
on that yeah okay if there's a vaccine
causing diabetes juvenile diabetes
rheumatoid arthritis text or that's
you will see that
oh and you can stratify by age by gender
by you know by in every way and you can
figure out exactly what's causing the
problems and then you can cure it
oh ahr cqs
develop not only he studied one of the
hmos an HMO in Boston called Harvard
Pilgrim
one of the ten big ones
they also developed a machine counting
system which they plugged in at Harvard
Pilgrim and what they found was at the
machine counting system was collecting
something like 40 40 times
a number of injuries that 40 to 99 times
the number of injuries that the
voluntary yes the rare system catches
yep and what they concluded was that
the various system was not just missing
99 of injuries it was missing more than
99 that's how bad it is and
the ah argue the plan was
roll their machine counting system out
to all the other hmos
and as soon as CDC showed that saw that
data and so an injury rate of 2.7
percent of one in every 40 people who
came in to get a vaccine were suffering
some kind of noteworthy injury
they said we are telling people that
injuries only occur one in a million and
um and they shut not only did they shut
down the whole project
but they stopped answering the phone
calls of their sister agency how do I
know that because hrq did a
peer-reviewed publication anybody can
look it up it's called Lazarus 2010.
and they say in it CEC no longer would
answer our phone calls once we give them
the data so
Tony fauci knows that system because
he's been told many many times
that system is on a Shelf at HHS
ready to roll out and if you really
wanted to know whether these vaccines
were injuring people
it can do it overnight and yet he left
it there and left us with the system
that he knows
is collecting probably less than one
percent of vaccine injuries so
there's some bad interaction between
Public Health
and medicine medicine being targeted at
helping the individual Public Health
being targeted at the overall rate of
various disorders Public Health
clearly feels entitled to lie right yes
that from the point of view lies it
claims they're Noble lives those who
look into these lives begin to wonder
what the hell is driving them but
nonetheless because Public Health feels
entitled to lie in order to simplify the
story so that people will for example uh
get vaccinated to control a contagious
disease
what it does if you don't take the data
that then allows people to understand
just what the rate of Adverse Events is
is it interrupts informed consent yeah
right your doctor doesn't know how
dangerous what you're being exposed to
is you don't know how dangerous and
therefore your doctor accepting that it
is worth the risk for you and you're
accepting that it is worth the risk for
you is it's something you're not capable
you're not capable of giving your
informed consent because you're
misinformed it's misinformed consent and
so
the funny thing funny there's nothing
funny about this but you say the Veris
system is built to fail we know we know
well that it dramatically under counts
is it getting three percent is it
getting ten percent is it getting one
percent we don't know but we know it's
not getting the majority of these events
and yet with these vaccines there's an
off the chart signal and off the chart
signal that when it is called in theirs
right inverse A system that is difficult
right despite the fact that the system
is built more than half of the vaccine
deaths
and if it occurred since the system was
put in place in 1986 over 40 years
um I have occurred in the last since the
roll out of these fact uh coveted
vaccines yeah there's like I it's not
just a hockey stick it's a right angle
to earn off the off of the graph yeah no
it's and so that tells you something and
then when that is pointed out to the
authorities what you get back is here
are the reasons that we don't believe
the various data which even if that was
correct it leaves you with no
understanding of how dangerous this is
it leaves you with no data which does
not it's not the same thing as an
indication that they're safe yeah so the
whole thing
it behaves like something that doesn't
want to know and the fact is when your
health or Worse your children's health
is dependent on some system that claims
to have rendered something safe but is
actively avoiding the information that
would tell you that it had made an error
that is the opposite of safe yeah well
you know and and here's how kind of
pervasive it is and how it's infiltrated
the media because everybody is part of
this
has been co-opted into this conspiracy
to tell people to Gaslight people who
say that they've been injured to
marginalize them to silence
um to deep platform um you know it's not
just me it was talking about
the generalized risks you know and
talking about science but it's a mother
or a dad or a child who lost a parent
who's as here's what happened when they
got the vaccine as a video of you know
the parent
um going into the seizure or the child
going to the seizures
immediately after vaccination and if you
put that out you will be you won't be
disappeared
oh one this is early in the pandemic you
know Hank Aaron was part of who I knew
was part of uh
um of a national campaign because blacks
are very very vaccine resistant a long
history of of mistrust of the medical
establishment and and
um and so the CDC was rounding uh civil
rights leaders and sports leaders who
are African-American to publicly take
the vaccine so
Hank Aaron went on stage and got the
vaccine at Emory University and then and
17 late days later he dies
and I wrote an article for the defender
for children's health events
and talked about it on my podcast and
um and I said I never said his death was
caused by the vaccine and nobody accused
me of saying that what I said
is that his death was part of a wave of
death or seeing in elderly people
immediately after vaccination which is
completely documented
and I and I was immediately attacked by
the New York Times by USA Today CNN ABC
NBC
thousands of news organizations
literally around the world
who were saying that I was lying and the
New York Times said that
they had spoken to the
um to the uh to the Atlanta
[Music]
uh corner
and at the Atlantic Corner had told them
that Hank Aaron did not suffer from a
vaccine injury that this was not it was
not vaccine related
so I called The Fulton County coroner
because I I wanted to know what task
they use
to make that determination because you
know mostly
vaccine injuries and deaths don't leave
fingerprints you don't know whether
person I have a heart attack or a stroke
that he would have had anyway whether
the vaccine contributed and I and I was
curious about how they had made such a
how they had such certitude about that
determination
and when I got the corner on the phone
they said to me we never saw Hank
Aaron's body we never performed an
autopsy the family buried that body and
nobody ever did a postmortem on it
and yet the New York Times reported a
lie and there's just this this
incredible impulse in the and you know
when I reported my conversation
it was just silence there was no effort
by the times or any of these other
papers to correct their error
it's um it's quite extraordinary
at everybody is part of this effort to
make sure that nobody believes that
people believe that vaccines are
completely safe
and completely effective and anybody who
disagrees with that at this you know I'm
punished yeah anybody anybody who asks
questions is is punished and the
punishment
um I think it is largely going to be
invisible to anybody who hasn't been on
the wrong end of it but the punishment
is absolutely ruthless it is gaslighting
and I must say it's not the first time
I've been demonized
um it is the first time I've been
demonized by something that clearly has
a many million dollar budget it is a
whole different experience and
um the idea
that there are
billions I presume hundreds of billions
of dollars at stake in the market for
covid treatments and vaccines and uh
that a cost of doing business would be
uh some number of millions to just
simply demonize those small number of
people who didn't get the memo and
raised obvious questions about all cause
mortality or number needed to treat or
absolute versus relative measures of
Effectiveness right
um you know it of course they're going
to be successful at controlling the
narrative especially when they have
Partners in uh in the tech platforms who
are willing to do their censoring for
them
now let me ask you this you raised the
issue of
the uh the kids vaccines which today is
in some ways a a historic day or maybe
yesterday was yesterday the CDC
unanimously recommended approval of the
vaccine uh for 5 to 11 year olds
um I did not understand that there was a
uh a hidden incentive for that that
would actually give the adult vaccines
um immunity as do I understand that
correctly yes
that is shocking I did know of the prior
story where the emergency use authorized
vaccine retained its uh liability
and that a person who after the vaccine
was given authorization
um not authorization given approval
a person who went in and got the
authorized but not approved vile even
though in theory they contained The
Identical uh substances of different
labels they had different labels but a
person who got vaccinated wouldn't even
know what they were vaccinated with and
therefore wouldn't understand that they
were actually being vaccinated with
something that gave the manufacturer
immunity from liability even though the
FDA had signed off on it at that point
so these games are everywhere and I will
say the the most common theme throughout
all of this seems to be accounting
Shenanigans right the label on the
bottle affects your ability to Sue or
not to sue somebody who dies
um with covid is presumed to have died
of covid a person who has been
vaccinated but hasn't been two weeks out
from their vaccine is treated as
unvaccinated all of these things are
used to create a story that is not true
um but in any case yesterday the CDC
unanimous recommendation for the 5 to 11
year olds to be vaccinated
I can see exactly zero medical
justification for this as you point out
healthy children do exceedingly well
with covet it's not a dangerous disease
to them what's more
I say a lifetime immunity to get
lifetime immunity so from the point of
view of a very Rama robust and broad
spectrum community that is going to
protect them against all variants and
unlike the vaccine immunity which is a
very narrow spectrum and which requires
and boosters year after year after year
and those boosters each come with a risk
of Adverse Events so from the point of
view of the medical well-being of a
child this is a very strange it's very
clear that it is damaging that you're
going to cause far more problems or
injuries than you're going to avert
and you know but the uh it seems also
clear that the rationale is economic
rather than a public health rationale
well I agree with you I also the more I
think about it the more this does feel
like a modern Tuskegee
a Tuskegee without race because
effectively these children are not in a
position to consent right just as
participants in the Tuskegee experiment
were not informed right they were told
they were going to get free health care
and they did not understand what what it
was that they were being signed up for
and what harm they might come to
this is effectively that with no medical
justification
we are apparently going to push vaccines
towards children who would be better off
if they got the disease out of the way
I mean we I want to be careful in saying
that because there is we do not know
that 20 years down the road from a
coveted infection that it is not going
to re-emerge and some harm come from it
but based on what we do know about covid
the harm to young healthy children is
absolutely minimal and that means that
the Adverse Events that children will
face if they are vaccinated are
uncompensated and the also you know
there's really strong indications for
example
you have the story of Maddie Gary oh we
know it's one of the third they're going
to give this to 26 million kids
and they only tested it on 1300.
and one of the 1300 we know at least one
of them
is spending their life in a wheelchair
with a feeding tube and that's just the
beginning of madagari's suffering her
life is now
a nightmare of agony
um so
what we have to assume you know if we if
we look at the reason we have clinical
trials
is to look at the risk
um if you give it to the entire
population so if there's a one in 1300
risk
of ending up in a wheelchair for life
with a feeding tube
I you have to extrapolate that out to 26
million people and you may be able to do
that in your head but I think it's like
20 to 35
000 kids who might who potentially are
now going to be exposed to that risk and
uh you know that's a much much higher
risk
than there is from that we know of from
covet well we have to leave open the
possibility that Maddie Gary was very
very very unlucky well yeah but here's
the thing
under federal law
the any injury that occurs during a
clinical trial must be attributed to the
intervention and so they legally The
Regulators and the company
must legally assume that that is a 1 in
1300 risk that's going to apply across
the population right that should be that
should be the presumption and then it
could be demonstrated that it was just a
fluke but of course short of that
demonstration we have to assume that
that's that's the Baseline but you know
if you're only going to test your
intervention on 1300 people before you
give it to 26 million you ought to be
stuck yes with whatever the outcome is
especially these these I mean I must
tell you the the recommendation to
vaccinate young children
for this shocks me more than anything
I've seen so far and I've been
repeatedly shocked but this is
so
Brazen and so indifferent to the
suffering of people who
cannot know better cannot presumably say
no
it
it's inconceivable to me that
um
let's put it this way as an evolutionary
biologist I almost never use the term
evil because I believe you almost never
see evil it's a terrible strategy right
it a morality is a good strategy you see
that regularly
sociopathy is a good strategy it's it's
an amorality but this is so
um yeah
so Brazen and the harm will come to
literal innocence that I I don't think
there's another term
I really do think that this is uh
um
this is an atrocity in the making and uh
I don't know what we do about it but I
do think maybe maybe because the
evidence is so clear that children
healthy children do not suffer serious
harms from covet itself and because even
the broken vares system captures this
huge signal for Adverse Events including
depths from these vaccines that many
people who have gone along with the
public health narrative so far
will detect that something is wrong
something must be wrong for us to be
dragging our children into this when
frankly they are a population that just
doesn't need this protection now what I
suspect is that in many of these
people's minds there's a conflation
between the well-being of the individual
and the control of the pandemic and
although I think it is an appalling
argument one could make a rational
argument for vaccinating children to
control the spread of the disease of
course these vaccines are not effective
at controlling spread but nonetheless
that might be on some people's minds but
even that
what healthy Society
transfers
hell risks from from
children how do you justify putting a
children at rest in order to uh Preserve
in order to protect all people
um you know listen
this is always this is like a baseline
philosophy 101
um you know uh a dilemma exercise and it
always has the same outcome as you don't
you know a government
cannot put one person at risk to save
somebody else you know you know that's
just something that we understand and
Western
liberal democracies and in western
civilization that you don't do that
and yet
um and not only is it other people but
it's kids
yeah I mean I I do I will push back a
little bit I do think we put one person
In Harm's Way to protect another we do
that when we draft people
I think it's called the trolley the
trolley problem yeah the trolley problem
whether you whether you pull the switch
there's six people are gonna get ahead
do you pull the switch and let the one
person and I think the answer is if
you're an individual that you may do
that but we don't let governments make
those decisions if possible because you
know once
once you give a government here's the
problem once you give a government
the right to sacrifice human life or the
good of the community
you're on a slippery slope to you know
the worst kind of
um
uh ruthless barbaric totalitarian
decision making yeah
you know
um because really it's better than you
can say well
is better for society you know old
people in our society don't make much
contribution and a 80 of our health care
costs go to people in the last year of
Life wouldn't it be better just to get
rid of them early and if Government can
make that decision it can make some
really brutal decisions and that's you
know what we saw
I'm not making the comparison with
Nazism because that also is a slippery
you know that's one of the reprehensible
things we saw
on the Nazis very early on is they
involved all of the doctors and saying
we're going to give give these yellow
cards to uh you're required to report
anybody in your practice who has
um who's intellectually disabled anybody
who's gay and anybody who has a physical
defects
and then the state would come and get
rid of those people
and we don't and that is the end point
when we start saying that government has
a right to you know to uh his children
too
they've theoretically saved older people
yeah it it makes no sense and just as a
hypothetical I mean I I agree with you
I'm
uh I don't find this a terribly long
stretch from uh Nazi I mean especially
Nazi doctor you know mengeles
experiments for example right
um well the doctors
were so badly behaved that they had to
have separate trials Nuremberg just for
the doctors and there wasn't as a single
doctor or Medical Association who's
looking forward in Germany you know
that's the astonishing thing well I I
want to be clear I'm not arguing that a
doctor who vaccinates children yes right
no of course not but I want to make
clear that what I'm saying is that a
government that can decide well for the
good of the many will sacrifice the few
May engage in Twin experiments for
example yes
um and I'm I uh have cousins who were
twins in mengeles experiments so I take
this very personally but let's just say
as a hypothetical here if the idea is it
is okay to put children at risk of
serious injuries in order to control a
pandemic that mostly harms the old and
the infirm then what is the distinction
between that and deciding that those in
need of a kidney can source that from
the population that we can just you know
people have two kidneys they can live
with only one and therefore you know
maybe the government can decide to
appropriate kidneys from healthy people
to people who need them right it's not
that different right it should be the
case
that we do not vaccinate children unless
it is in the interest of those children
to be vaccinated yeah I think that's the
bottom line that is the bottom line yeah
I think everybody the stuff that we're
talking about everybody anybody can
dispute it
I I don't think I think it's pretty hard
to dispute that statement yep I think so
too and it's also important to point out
that
the original premise which is there's no
evidence
of accidentally children will protect
adults right yeah you know right so
somehow again the driver seems to be
um vaccinate everybody
uh there seems to be games played with
legal liability that us lay people don't
know anything about you know never in
the discussion of uh whether or not to
authorize vaccination of 5 to 11 year
olds did I hear that uh the liability of
adult vaccines was somehow in play that
seems like an important consideration it
seems like a place where if corruption
was going to rear its ugly head you
would expect to see it and yet it was
never mentioned so where's the Press
I mean did you see it was it disgusting
it's not in the Press yeah that's uh
that's a remarkable remarkable fact it
will be breaking news on this podcast
right
um
well so
I think we're heading towards wrapping
up here
um there are of course a dozen things I
uh I know that we haven't touched upon
that we probably should but of course
what we have touched upon is already
fairly mind-bending and um people are
going to I think need some uh
some room to to digest it uh
where do you foresee where do you
foresee us going your book comes out on
the 16th
remind people
your book is the real Anthony fauci it
is uh an amazing read it's beautifully
written and
um really my experience and again I
haven't I haven't come close to
finishing the book yet but my experience
is almost every paragraph is shocking in
its own right
um
what do you foresee happening do you
think this book is going to uh wake
people up to the danger that that the
pandemic is being mismanaged and that
um Anthony fauci is somewhere in the
center of that
oh it's hard know
um
predict what
I really stopped making predictions Brad
because I have been consistently wrong
about how low I think you know how bad
things whether we've hit bottom yeah
that we've hit bottom so I
you know I really my
um
my Approach is to just keep trying to
get the truth out trying to pursue the
truth by trying to be
you know I'd be a good human being
myself and try not to not to do things
that polarized people
um but to constantly reach out to
people who disagree with me and try to
find some common ground you know because
I think we're in a
we're in the worst epic polarization in
this country since at least uh Civil War
I I see the same very very dangerous
um and we're gonna lose you know this
country
um or at risk of losing it we've already
lost many of the
he's very very uh important institutions
of our democracy and we need to figure
out a way to reclaim them and we're not
going to do that by fighting each other
no and I will say
um your uh very clear in your thinking
you're very easy to get along with I
think frankly in some sense uh it has
been easier to demonize you than it has
been to deal with your arguments and
that's why you faced the brutal campaign
that you have faced
um maybe there are a couple things we
should take care of before we before we
finally wrap this up
um without putting words in your mouth I
do want to have a sense of
is there such a thing as an anti-vaxxer
are you one how should we think about
this
there are people who are any vaccine who
are just believe that vaccines are
um are always
am messing with immune system is
misguided and that way to
at basically you know it's the old
argument with Pastor or is it the
terrain if you protect if you build your
immune system
um
is that are you then do you become
resistant to disease and there's very
good evidence that healthy people that
well-nourished people people who
societies with good Sanitation
um
don't get sick from infectious disease
and in fact
or you know the cdce has done a series
of studies
I'm one of them you know is important
it's called
i-r-g-u-y-e-r it's published in
Pediatrics in uh 2000
and it's by a CDC and and I and uh Johns
Hopkins scientists
and they looked at the issue about
whether vaccines and actually anything
to do with decline in mortalities from
infectious disease which is momentous
medical event in the 28th that occurred
in the beginning of the 20th century
and what they found was that vaccines
and almost nothing to do with The
Disappearance of infectious disease is
that it was not in fact attributable to
Medical interventions at all but mainly
engineering the development of flush
toilets of Sanitation of hydrogen
chlorinated water
um and then good nutrition roads that
could bring oranges from Florida and
those kind of interventions there's
other uh studies many other ones there's
another one called McKinley and McKinley
back in the 70s
that was required reading in almost
every medical school in our country that
say the same thing so the people who are
completely anti-vaxxed
have arguments they're not crazy people
I'm not one of those people what I think
is I'm not I guess any intervention if
it can prove itself with science
my position is that we should have
double-blind placebo-controlled studies
prior to the licensing of vaccines and
if if it if it shows that people who
take that vaccine are more likely to
live and have better health than people
who don't and I'm for it
if you can't show that then I'm against
it and that is completely my position
um oh I think the term antifax
is a pejorative that is applied to me
in order to marginalize me to make me
look like I'm uh you know I I I'm crazy
or
and that people don't have to listen to
my arguments they can dismiss me for who
I am and so and I think that's so much
of the strategy is to silence debate
rather than actually conducted and
entertainment which is what we ought to
be doing in a democracy democracy is
about
a floors on the free flow of information
at least that's the theory then
policies that are annealed in The
Cauldron of debate are more likely to uh
you know to steer us in a good direction
than if we silence dissonance yes and I
think
um you know there is the issue of
censorship and there's the issue of
making an example of people who do what
you've done and what I have been doing
um and it's very effective that you can
spook people into not seeing the the
truth that's right in front of them by
uh showing that you can drive up the
costs of those
who do see it now I will say
um I don't know that my position is
identical to yours uh as you've stated
it but it sounds very similar
um I will add
uh not only I'm I still love
um the mechanism of vaccination the idea
of putting information into a system
that can use that information to fend
off diseases it has never seen before I
still believe that that's an incredibly
elegant mechanism but my guess is
that it needs to be used sparingly and
that the market forces that see you know
any vaccination that can be justified in
a context where harms can be downplayed
and benefits can be over uh hyped and
and all of this that what we ought to be
realizing is that like everything else
that there is some
uh sweet spot that probably there are
some diseases for which there is a net
benefit for this mechanism we ought to
identify which ones those are but most
importantly
I don't think we are capable of
identifying which things are in the
interest of patients which things are in
the interest of society if there is a
for-profit sector
driving that has inputs into the
regulatory apparatus that's simply a
deal breaker from the point of view of
good governance proper regulation and
the protection of patients and citizens
from harm and so really you know
I think we're in the very
ugly position of being demonized for
being against
treatments as if this is born of some
Luddite impulse right rather than being
alarmed at the degree to which
corruption has hijacked this process and
created a mandate for products that
create alarming adverse event signals
right so I don't know how we get out of
that trap I don't know how we get people
to view the concern as about corruption
and uh informed consent rather than
about some you know Paleolithic
resistance to modern medicine
yeah I don't have any uh anything to add
to that I would be I wouldn't you know
enlarge on it I think that's exactly
right
you know we need to rationalize the
marketplace and we need to rationalize
the regulations of that its objective is
to serve Public Health rather than to
serve the profit interests of companies
who are making these products
yep I think that's uh very well
summarized all right well
Bobby Kennedy I hope I continue to see
you on the airwaves sorry this isn't
there your swan song I hope so too
um you know I guess that depends in part
on whether or not um the people who can
hear us uh will defend what we're doing
because it's obviously I mean this is
what free speech is for it is for having
difficult discussions like this and uh
anyway I applaud you for for being so
dogged uh in fighting the good fight and
uh I I'll share a trench with you
anytime thank you thank you all right be
well everyone
[Music]